yeah i just you know
i think they're like you know i think
the one the one thing i told like shipes
and hovain when i first met you was like
yo he's he's like got a good head on his
shoulders you know
you're not you're not like a stupid
ignorant kid you know what i'm saying
and i just i don't want to see like i
don't want to wake up one day and open
up my phone
and it'd be like young and eggs got shot
yeah for sure because we see i do this
shit's happening so much or i'll
interview somebody
and they die
yo bro like this [ __ ] is real dawg like
you know what i'm saying and that's why
you know
i just like i definitely know i
definitely know it's real that i said
i've been shot a lot no i know and you
know you've lost family members yeah
so you know what i'm saying i already
know what life is like i know what's
like what's going on you know what i'm
saying
and you got kids right nine no you don't
got kids well that's good got
you know that's i mean you know so you
out here then
[Laughter]
[Music]
but you got your brothers to take care
of yeah for sure you know what i'm
saying i got my girl too chloe
got my mom i got the whole family life
for sure like how how's mom like when my
like how
what was what was your mom's first
impression when she saw who i smoked
and i'm on my best friend she loved that
song i'm gonna love this one she
played it all day my mom loved all my
music the video was that i think the
video was like the
the icing like like the icing on the
cake because it was just like these guys
are on a golf course
so crazy ridiculous that video puts a
band it puts one it puts one from the
golf course to a house
no y'all did it the right way and then
we just went crazy i just
i already knew i was gonna do it like
you guys everybody i already said like
we all knew it
but like they don't see they knew it was
gonna be bad but they ain't know it's
gonna be
this big mm-hmm i knew i was gonna get
this bit because i like i say i've
already been so i know what
like i know what people want i know what
they know i'm saying
see the people be want stuff like that
for me right but i'm not giving
i don't like giving them that type of
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying see
but i gotta say bro but better my momma
don't
two times she she played all day like
your mom ever tell you like i don't like
this [ __ ] that [ __ ] wasn't it i like the
[ __ ] you said on this
oh man never told me never she just did
i mean even when i get talking about her
owners she never told me that because
she know
all this [ __ ] you're telling your story
man